vladimir poutine et tu dis c'est
peut-être la principale information
de ce conseil de défense il étudie la
possibilité de reconnaître les régions
séparatistes en ukraine donc celle de
louhansk et de donetsk à la demande
bruno daroux des séparatistes eux-mêmes
et du parlement russe également oui il
ya déjà une demande qui a été faite en
ce sens un projet de loi même qui a été
voté par la chambre basse la semaine
dernière au russe la douma la semaine
dernière ce qui pas un projet de loi du
cou qui prend force de loi tout de suite
quitte un projet de loi si vous voulez
qu'ils aient qui estime qu'il faudrait
reconnaître l'indépendance des deux
républiques autoproclamées de donetsk
est lougansk mais qui fait un appel au
président poutine parce que c'est à lui
que revient selon les procédures russe
que revient la responsabilité en quelque
sorte de reconnaître l'indépendance de
ces deux républiques et effectivement
l'exercice de communication assez
incroyable auquel
nous venons d'assister qui se et qui se
poursuit c'est pour dire
en fait si on en arrive là c'est ainsi
moscou reconnaît l'indépendance de
service parce que on aura tout essayé
pour mettre en oeuvre les accords de
minsk qui devrait régir l'avenir de ces
deux territoires mais que voilà selon
les russes l'ukraine fait tout pour ne
pas mettre en oeuvre ces accords refusé
d'amender sa constitution refuse de
négocier avec directement avec les
séparatistes pro russes demandent à
négocier avec la russie donc nous nous
prêtons à ce jeu des négociations
mais quand nous proposons des choses
l'ukraine fait comme si elle ne les
entendait pas donc on voit bien en fait
tout ce qui est en place là c'est pour
dire là et là encore on n'est que sur le
don bassin c'est pour dire sur cette
question du dombass nous nous sommes
allés jusqu'au bout du bout de la
logique
des accords de minsk nous avions la
volonté de mettre en oeuvre ces hackers
de win ce qui est des choses ont été
écrites noir sur blanc 2015
l'ukraine fait tout pour ne pas les
mettre en oeuvre donc à un moment voilà
en fait on en était là ce qui ne va pas
falloir reconnaître l'indépendance de
ces deux républiques et même à l'excès
et même un excellent combat c'est ce que
demande est l'un des protagonistes et
vladimir poutine lui a dit pour l'argent
il n'en est pas question enfin il n'a
pas répondu à la question y voilà il a
pas répondu à la question c'était à il
faut il accepter le dombass au sein de
la fédération de russie
c'était formulé comme ça et de la grille
mais voilà où on en est pas là nous on
voit bien toujours cette même tactique
en fait c'est à dire qu'on fait monter
la menace très très loin cire que l'on
sent qu'on est à deux doigts que la
russie reconnaissent l'indépendance de
ces territoires et peut-être même que
ces deux territoires soient rattachés à
la russie c'est une forme de pression
donc pour que les choses bougent et ça a
été pareil sur les autres sujets mais
malgré tout le dialogue se poursuit il
n'y aura pas de rencontre entre poutine
et
byden comme l'avait supposé l'elysée pas
pour l'instant on trouve pour l'instant
voilà mais la prochaine étape c'est
jeudi entre sergueï lavrov et anthony
blinken en fait on a vraiment
l'impression que
le fait de montrer comme ça à livre
ouvert devant l'opinion mondiale à
conseil de défense quand même qui est
par définition en principe plutôt à huit
clos c'est un énorme coup de coeur de
valdivia routine pour dire écoutez
pour notre récit et vaut largement celui
des occidentaux et nos demandes sont
légitimes et les occidentaux ne veulent
absolument le faire donc finalement les
responsables de cette crise ce n'est pas
nous comme les occidentaux ce sont les
occidentaux qui sont allés beaucoup trop
loin qui ont développé l'otan beaucoup
trop loin qu'ils ne veulent pas revenir
sur la politique de la porte ouverte qui
ne veulent pas s'engager sur le fait que
l'ukraine ne rejoindra pas l'otan
vladimir poutine dis moi on me propose
un moratoire enfin un moratoire ce
serait uniquement dans l'intérêt des
occidentaux c'est à dire on attendait
quelques années dans quelques années le
même problème se reposeraient pareil
pour la question de l'indivisibilité de
la sécurité sur le continent européen
qui avait pourtant été actée disent les
russes dans les années 90 quand on
parlait de partenariat entre la russie
et l'otan c'est-à-dire que la sécurité
d'un bloc ne pouvait pas compromettre la
sécurité dans notre bloc ce qui serait
le cas si l'ukraine rejoint l'otan donc
voilà sur tout c'est sur tous ces sujets
en fait là ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que la russie veut montrer
qu'elle fait le maximum par la voie
diplomatique et que le problème ce sont
les lunellois là et qu'elle négocie
quelqu'un qu'elle est pleine de bonne
volonté et qu'en face il n'y a que des
portes fermées pour le coup et que donc
ce sont les occidentaux qui portent la
responsabilité de ce qui pourrait se
passer puisque on al'impression qu'avec
ce conseil de défense ça veut dire là on
a quand même tout essayé et maintenant
que reste-t-il vladimir poutine qui a
souligné qu'il a passé beaucoup de temps
avec emmanuel macron au téléphone
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin dit il hier
soir et puis il dit
le président poutine dit qu emmanuel
macron lui disait qu'il y avait eu des
changements
aux états unis mais il n'a pas pu
préciser quels étaient ces changements
ça c'est difficile voilà c'est un peu ça
peut brûler
le président français de la difficulté
un devoir jouer un rôle de médiateur
mais effectivement il dit le président
français me dit que les américains sont
prêts à changer leurs positions et quand
je pose la question mais sur quel point
il n'y a pas de réponse c'est ce que dit
vladimir poutine y aura sans doute des
précisions du côté de l'elysée la seule
avancée mais en fait on tourne un peu en
rond parce que ça a déjà été dit la
seule avancée que reconnaissait real
lavrov
entre les russes et les occidentaux
c'est sur des sujets que les russes
continuaient à présenter comme des
sujets importants mis secondaire sur le
contrôle des armements les missiles de
longue et moyenne portée la transparence
l'estimation du risque mutuelles etc et
les russes disent bas vous voyez nous on
est de bonne foi bah oui là dessus on
avance on avance on est sur les autres
sujets c'est pas nous qui ne voulons pas
avancer ce sont les occidentaux et et
c'est ce que dit seriez là bref il ya eu
des petites avancées dans la réponse des
occidentaux en termes de sécurité en
europe où il va cesser c'est sur ces
sujets là que je viens que je viens de
le développer que les russes considèrent
comme les sujets secondaires mais il dit
a eu des avancées
donc ça c'est bien mais comparé à nos
principales demandes
qui sont donc l'otan qui ne doit pas qui
ne doit pas s'élargir bien sûr le droit
enfin une sécurité véritablement encadré
qui ne nuise à personne et la mise en
oeuvre des accords de mines ce que vous
ne vous rappelez peut-être les accords
de minsk donc 2014 accor qui a été de
2015 qui ont été conclus après une
longue nuit de négociations entre
engrais merkel est absolument hollande
va devenir poutine et le président
ukrainien de l'époque qui prévoit
effectivement qu'il ya un retrait des
armes lourdes de ces deux républiques
autoproclamées qui prévoit effectivement
qu'ensuite il y ait des consultations
entre l'ukraine et les populations sur
le fait de savoir quel statut
particulier effectivement c'est dans les
accords de minsk devrait obtenir le
débat au sein de la fédération de
l'ukraine si vous voulez l'idée c'est
d'accorder comme une large part
d'autonomie assez le territoire à
condition qu'elle reste partie de
l'ukraine et les russes là dessus 10
mais nous on est prêt à avancer mais
dans les accords de minsk il est
également prévu que
le gouvernement ukrainien négocie
directement avec les séparatistes
pro-russes il refuse ça ils ne veulent
pas amender la reconstitution l'eure
s'est inscrit dans les accords de minsk
ils ne veulent pas accorder un statut
particulier quitte à prendre le temps
pour voir quels types de statuts
particuliers comme c'est prévu dans les
accords de minsk bref l'ukraine ne fait
tout pour bloquer les accords de minsk
s'est pas de nous qui bloquons ce sont
les ukrainiens donc on voit bien tout le
plaidoyer pro domo de la russie c'est de
dire sur les questions autant et
sécurité nous avons des demandes tout à
fait légitime les occidentaux sont allés
trop loin nous sommes prêts à négocier
des occidentaux de mouches pas sur le
dôme basse pareil nous sommes de bonne
volonté est là c'est l'ukraine qui ne
bouge pas et donc cette possible
reconnaissance des régions séparatistes
on en reparle dans l'édition de 16h
merci beaucoup bruno et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis à tout de suite